What is important about the dinner scene? Why does the director spend his time on such a simple matter?
This will be the focus of our discussion today. Welcome to Now You See it
Don't interrupt me.
I think the dinner scene is one of the most powerful and revealing scenes in the movie.
It’s not just about people eating more, but about communicating.
And the communication mentioned refers to the action of getting along at the table.
The director uses the dinner scene to reveal the relationship between each character. How do they get along with each other, or can’t
But I think there is more content at the same time we are going to know the typical dinner "program"
You eat, talk about your day, talk about a few jokes and call it the night.
And when the dinner "program" in the movie has a problem, we will pay special attention because we are used to the typical "program".
That's why the dinner scene has many potential possibilities.
Whether it is humor
Or dramatic
Let's take a look at the three steps of the dinner scene: eating, conflicts and accidents
Whether you are a contract killer or a god, you need to eat and eat to make you like a personal class.
Eating can make characters appear like our general humanity while allowing us to enter their world, and then create links
We can't be associated with the role of stealing diamonds or being shot but can link a debate on the table.
Dinner scenes can make us resonate with the characters
Tarantino uses the dinner scene in the movie "Scrambled" and "Black Chasing Order" to bring us into the movie world.
Just when we see that the character is eating happily
Suddenly shooting and robbing the restaurant gave us more shock, because we just saw who they are.
Human beings, eating at the same human beings
When people get together to eat, they should be in harmony.
However, things are not always the case. Instead, the dinner scene is the perfect way to show conflicts.
When people are angry and leave
Break the plate
Or being isolated
This reveals a lot of information about the role rather than using "saying"
Therefore, a successful typical dinner "procedure" cannot convey more information.
Dinner is not always smooth in real life, not even in movies.
Since we understand how this "program" may be
It would be more interesting when things didn’t happen as expected.
Or more dramatic
From the familiar dinner scene to the alien shape from someone’s chest
Increased fear
If dinner is just "dinner", it will be very boring.
The director will not waste any shots, such as a simple dinner scene without conveying other important information.
That's why I don't need to use "say" for movie movies.
It doesn't need to say "These two are not good" or "This person is just like you and me."
It can be used to "play"
Use "play" instead of "speak" to make the film a new level
And the dinner scene can be very brilliant.
Thank you for watching